en matière de risques pour la santé
associés aux usages des technologies et
au télétravail il y a bien sûr les
troubles liés au travail prolongé sur
écran fatigue visuelle maux de tête
il y aussi la survenue de troubles
musculo squelettiques qui se manifestent
sous forme de douleur douleur à la nuque
aux épaules au dos aux poignets aux
mains ces risques professionnels
auxquels sont plus longuement exposé les
télétravailleurs car ils sont moins
interrompu prennent moins de pauses de
moins longue durée et se déplacent peu
lorsqu'il télétravail depuis leur
domicile
ces risques sont bien connus et font
l'objet d'attentions particulières de la
part des entreprises mais il ya aussi
les risques psychiques
moins visible plus insidieux qui ne se
manifestent pas nécessairement dans
l'immédiat avant la pandémie
les travaux de recherche internationaux
y compris les nôtres révélait déjà
depuis plusieurs années que l' usage des
technologies mobiles favorise le
prolongement de l'activité
professionnelle au domicile et
l'extension du travail au delà des
espaces temps qui sont habituellement
traditionnellement dédié au travail
aboutissant à un accroissement de la
charge de travail et au renforcement de
forme d'addiction addictions au travail
comme addiction aux technologies ceux
ciblant en particulier le télétravail
montre qu'il est associé à une
intensification une densification est
une extension du travail
autrement dit que des télétravailleurs
et l'été les travailleuses travail plus
plus longtemps et mobilise plus de
ressources pour s'acquitter de leur
tâche en résulte une charge de travail
excessive un sentiment de stress et de
pression tant du point de vue
professionnel que du point de vue
personnel qui peuvent conduire les
télétravailleurs ossur travail jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'épuisement professionnel à cet
accroissement de la charge mentale est
temporel du travail s'ajoute une
perturbation de l'organisation spatiale
et temporelle du travail qui conduit
bien souvent à la disparition des
frontières entre vie personnelle et vie
professionnelle
un envahissement de la sphère privée
domestique possible source de tensions
et de conflits au sein de la cellule
familiale
or on sait déjà depuis plus de 50 ans
dans nos champs de recherche que la
perception de conflit entre vie
professionnelle et vie privée et
génératrice de trous
de la santé physique et mentale
d'absentéisme et de turnover parmi les
facteurs qui expliquent le sur
engagement des télétravailleurs
plusieurs approches insiste sur
l'importance des représentations du
télétravail certains salariés peuvent en
effet se sentir redevable vis-à-vis de
leur entreprise qui leur accorde un
privilège auquel tout le monde n'a pas
accès et fournirait davantage d'efforts
pour s'acquitter de cette dette
mais ils sont aussi susceptibles
d'éprouver une forme de culpabilité
intériorisé lorsqu'il se compare à
d'autres
considérant qu'ils ont la chance de
pouvoir travailler en échappe à
certaines contraintes en évitant les
trajets en évitant les transports en
s'extirpant d'environnement de travail
jugées parfois délétère
ou encore plus récemment en étant moins
exposées au risque de contamination
puisque travaillant depuis chez eux
ce sentiment de culpabilité peut générer
une forme de pression et les pousser à
vouloir faire plus faire mieux à
travailler sans limite jusqu'à l'usure
il y aussi la manière dont le
télétravail est perçue est jugé par les
autres avec un risque d'opposition entre
ceux qui vont au front et ceux qui n'y
vont pas ceux qui se mettent en danger
et ceux qui restent à l'abri
le risque d'activation de préjugés et de
comportements discriminatoires au sein
des équipes ou entre les équipes source
de fragilisation de la cohésion sociale
le risque de division entre ceux qui
font et ce qui ne ferait pas associé à
la crainte de perdre la reconnaissance
de ses pairs et de l'encadrement et la
nécessité de devoir faire ou refaire ses
preuves' de rendre visible le travail
mais ce sur engagement est aussi
susceptible d'être renforcée par les
pratiques manageriales si l'on s'accorde
sur l'idée que le télétravail est
propice au développement de modes de
management par objectifs il ne doit pas
signifier que l'on laisse pour autant
les salariés livrés à eux mêmes sans
repères sociaux ni repère temporel sur
lesquels s'appuyer pour s'organiser sans
savoir comment s'y prendre et par où
commencer
ce qui génère de l'anxiété et du stress
à l'image des constats issus des
recherches scientifiques internationales
de grande enquête nationale menée avant
la pandémie observé un lien significatif
entre développement du télétravail et
exposition aux risques psychosociaux
dans diverses organisations
en termes d'horaires imprévisible de
perception de charge de travail et de
tensions avec l'entourage professionnel
et c'est peut-être d'ailleurs sur ce
dernier point que réside le risque
majeur du travail à distance risque de
fragmentation des collectifs de
dégradation de la qualité des relations
de restriction du nombre de personnes
que l'on côtoie de diminution des
échanges informels et de moments de
convivialité pourtant indispensable à la
construction des savoirs et savoir-faire
au partage de valeur à l'épanouissement
professionnel mais aussi et surtout
indispensable à la construction de la
santé au travail
en effet la cohésion au sein des
collectifs la qualité des relations
l'instauration de forme de soutiens
sociaux sont reconnus comme protégeant
les salariés des effets délétères de
conditions de travail dégradées et des
facteurs de risques psycho sociaux à
cela sa de juin l'absence de relations
sociales au cours de la journée de
télétravail qui est lié à un
accroissement de la sédentarité propres
au télétravail au d'homicide et qui
vient renforcer le sentiment d'isolement
voire d'exclusion professionnelle et
sociale qui fragilise les
télétravailleurs et d'été les
travailleuses on comprend dès lors à
quel point le rôle des managers de
proximité est essentielle dans la
manière dont ils animeront coordonneront
porteront les collectifs c'est en partie
sur eux que repose la réussite des modes
d'organisation du travail mais en partie
seulement
j'en viens justement mon second point
relatif au mode de management et à leurs
effets sur la santé
les travaux de recherche mené depuis
plus de vingt ans et qui ont d'ailleurs
été confortée par ceux réalisés pendant
la période de pandémie
ces travaux montrent que les mécanismes
à l'oeuvre sont relativement similaires
que l'on soit en présentiel ou en
distance yale et met en lumière les
conditions de performance et de santé
des travailleurs il montre que les
managers qui valorise le travail réalisé
par les salariés qui portent de
l'intérêt à ce qu'il disait à ce qu'ils
font qui montrent leur satisfaction du
travail accompli qui font preuve de
soutien en termes des deux
d'informations de conseils apportés mais
aussi qu'ils encouragent qui sont allés
coûte qui font preuve d'empathie qui
laisse des marges de manoeuvre et
confèrent de l'autonomie qui apprennent
à déléguer et accordent leur confiance
par leur pratique et les postures qu'ils
adoptent favorisent la santé des
salariés
les protègent de l'érosion
professionnels en revanche lorsque les
orientations et politique managériale
qui sont propres aux organisations et
souvent relayés malgré eux par les
managers de proximité conduisent donc
lorsque c'est ses orientations et
politique managériale conduisent les
salariés à se sentir sous pression
lorsque l'on cherche à contrôler
étroitement l'avancée du travail des
salariés la nature des tâches qu'ils
accomplissaient la manière dont il les
accompli ce que l'on exige d'eux
d'exécuter des tâches dans des délais
réduits voire intenable qu'on les
sollicite dans l'urgence tout en
exigeant des réponses immédiates qu on
les mobilise de manière intrusive
en dehors des temporalités en principe
dédié à la vie hors travail
alors dans ces conditions les salariés
sont aussi plus susceptibles de
ressentir du stress de se sentir
pressurisée d'être débordé avec le temps
de s'épuiser professionnellement les
études menées auprès des
télétravailleurs ont qui plus est
démontré que ceux qui sont les plus
performants les plus pro actif les plus
impliqués les plus satisfaits sont aussi
ceux qui sont le moins de contrôler et
le plus soutenu par leur manager mais
aussi qu'il bénéficie d'appuis
techniques et matériels tout comme de
dispositifs d'accompagnement et de
soutien au sein de l'organisation actes
et est reconnu par les instances de
direction bien avant l'époque la
pandémie les managers et en particulier
les managers de proximité ont traversé
une crise identitaire ont été pris en
étau ils se sont progressivement
éloignés de leur coeur de métier pour
répondre aux exigences bureaucratiques
toujours plus de traçage du reporting de
process de procédure sommé de rendre des
comptes tout en étant dans
l'impossibilité de faire remonter le
réel du travail pourtant indispensables
au fonctionnement du travail et son
organisation mais ils ont depuis
plusieurs mois est plus que jamais joué
un rôle essentiel et l'expérience
inédite du travail en période de
pandémie peut être l'occasion de
transformer les anciens modèles de
dessiner de nouvelles directions
d'expérimenter de nouveaux possibles si
l'on considère les risques identifiés
que l'on se donne les moyens de les
réduire de les enrayer de mieux les
prévenus
il n'est pas exclu que les nouveaux
modes d'organisation du travail à
condition qu'ils soient étayées débattu
et penser collectivement réévalué de
manière continue autrement dit à
condition qu'il soit co construit et
ancrée dans le travail réel soit
l'occasion de retisser du lien social au
sein des organisations de favoriser le
bien-être et la qualité de vie des
managers et des salariés et de fait de
gagner en performance
merci beaucoup
ça ouvre des dizaines de voix de
réflexion donc merci pour ce démarrage
monsieur l'oublier chaumont si vous
voulez prendre la suite vous écoute
bonjour et c'est le président et bonjour
madame et messieurs les membres de cette
commission merci 1 pour votre invitation
alors pour me présenter rapidement donc
je suis effectivement membre du conseil
d'administration de vous l'avez dit de
la station l'association attend des
salles de psychologie du travail de
langue française
je suis aussi coordinateur du réseau de
recherche des psychologues du travail en
france dont qui réunit à peu près de 21
équipes de recherche ou ses thématiques
de du travail des organisations au
travail et puis également donc titulaire
de la chaire de psychologie du trailer
mais travaux portent sur les incidences
des transformations digitales sur la
question du travail et la santé au
travail et notamment par exemple sur les
effets de la sphère connexion des
percussions de la reconnaissance aussi
de cette activité qui devient de plus en
plus distante et invisible notamment
également j'essaye de ce qu'on appelle
prospecter l'acceptation des
technologies émergentes celles qui ne
sont encore pas là mais on essaye de
d'appréhender un peu leurs incidences
possibles est favorable ou défavorable
sur le travail et l'activité la santé
des salariés notamment l'intelligence
artificielle les cowboys la réalité des
mercis contrats et des laboratoires des
start up et puis aussi c'est identifier
cette nouvelle forme de travail
ces nouvelles formes ce nouveau mode
d'activité et puis voir le rôle et la
fonction que je joue justement ces
technologies dans ces transformations et
comment mieux accompagnons si ces
évolutions qui
pour certaines comme on vient d'en
parler là comme le télétravail
paraissent inéluctables mais pour
qu'elle soit pas le faire accepter coûte
que coûte mais rendre acceptable ces
situations particulières
ça c'est important parce que je crois
que là on a une question cruciale sur
l'acceptabilité on parle d'acceptabilité
d'un certain nombre d'éléments liés au
confinement si on parle d' acceptation
d'acceptabilité on pourra faire la
nuance aussi sur cette question des
technologies de nouvelles formes de
travail
alors du coup emilie vert que je connais
très bien a parfaitement bien résumé
tout un ensemble de problématiques on
partage donc je vais pas revenir là
dessus je vais essayé de déborder c'est
pour ça je n'ai pas préparé mais de
construire par rapport à dix courses et
donc vous allez entendre et même chose
donc essayer de donc de porter un petit
peu alors peut-être définir ce que c'est
la psychologie du travail peut-être
parce que voilà on arrive mais vous
connaissez pas forcément moi je dirais
en un mot on ne soigne pas les individus
aux fans de travail c'est ça alors que
moi je ne sais pas soigné individus
c'est pas mon rôle c'est des collègues
techniciens d'investir du travail mais
nous on soigne le travail pour permettre
finalement aux gens de de bien de
développer leur pouvoir d'agir rare
capacité d'action de développer leurs
compétences
et puis d'apporter la reconnaissance de
leur activité et aussi qu'ils puissent
s'exprimer se reconnaître dans ce qu'ils
font et de les reconnaître aussi dans ce
qu'ils font et l'idée rapport à la santé
au travail c'est de ne pas voir
l'individu comme intrinsèquement
défaillant au fragile mais ce sont les
conditions de travail qui le rendent
fragile est défaillant et dans de ces
conditions de travail c'est là nous on
agit pour essayer de proposer un
environnement un contexte de travail
notamment avec ces nouvelles formes
trice nouvelle aude était trahi ses
technologies où l'individu encore une
fois pu s'épanouir peut s'exprimer et
veut réaliser on a un travail de qualité
du coup ce que l'on voit alors
apparaître
c'est effectivement que malheureusement
dans cette urgence à déployer ces
nouvelles modalités de travail et les
technologiques les accompagnent dont
elle travaille aussi ce que j'appelle
plus généralement le très médiatisé 10 à
distance donc on a le trail mobile une
halte et traille mentionna travail
nomade consignes des spécificités de ces
nouvelles formes de travail
on a aussi dansé caractérisation de ce
travail un travail qui est éclatée
éclaté entre les individus éclaté entre
des hommes et des machines où l'activité
devient de plus en plus dématérialisé 18
alizés qu'elle devient de plus en plus
insaisissable invisible on l'a dit et du
coup qui dans lequel l'individu a du mal
à se reconnaître puisque effectivement
sur une activité qui est de plus en plus
éloignés le client est éloigné l'objet
de travail et éloigner le processus dans
lequel intervient c'est parce qu'on fait
on sait pas ce qu'on produit donc il ya
aussi cette idée qu'on a du mal à se
reconnaître dans ce qu'on apporte dans
ce qu'on produit sa valeur ajoutée et
puis on a aussi du mal à se faire
reconnaître ce qu'ont apporté et ses
jugements de reconnaissance d'utilité à
quoi je sers à quoi sert mon travail
c'est un élément essentiel de la
reconnaissance au travail et cette
reconnaissance et l'armature de la santé
psychique et et de l'identité
professionnelle aussi donc on est dans
des formes de travail si vous voulez ou
et là moi je suis un peu pessimiste par
rapport un peu aller aux évolutions à
venir où on a maintenu des situations
ordinaires dans un contexte
extraordinaire ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que les modalités de travail
qu'on connaissait en travail sédentaire
présentiel ont été maintenus dans un
contexte distant éclaté avec des
exigences nouvelles et avec une défiance
et une méfiance vis-à-vis du salarié on
multiplie les outils les environnements
pour contrôler et superviser l'autonomie
dont parlait mais l'hiver qui est ce
crucial
alors parfois faire attention puisque
l'autonomie peut être imposée c'est ce
que j'appelle mon la prescription de la
subjectivité c'est à dire que on dit aux
individus d'être beaucoup plus innovant
plus créatif plus autonome alors qu'ils
n'ont pas les compétences n'ont pas été
formés n'ont pas été accompagnés esaü de
prendre cette responsabilité là c'est
difficile mais en tout cas ou alors la
prescription de la rationalité c'est à
dire que justement l'autonomie fait peur
on sait pas ce qu'ils font derrière on
sait pas s'ils sont bien dans ont
développé un outil de tracking le times
tracking par exemple se sont laissé ce
logiciel qui permet d'identifier si les
individus sont non seulement face à leur
écran mais les frappes et zoom pour
donner un exemple vous avez quand vous
parlez on verra tout à l'heure je
passais zoom mais l'écran qui s'allume
quand la personne parle et donc on est
capable de produire les courbes en fin
de journée aux entreprises pour montrer
qui a le plus parlé dans la journée qui
a plu
prix le plus la parole d'un jour n'est
donc on développe des formes de
reconnaissance au travail dont on sait
qu encore une fois qu'ils sont
essentiels est importante mais qui ne
révèle pas du tout de ce que fait
vraiment le l'individu voyez c'est une
évaluation quantitative mais pas
qualitative du travail et du coup
l'individu se reconnaît pas là dedans et
c'est pas parce que j'ai parlé beaucoup
que j'ai dit des choses intéressantes
j'espère que c'est pas mon cas bref et
et du coup il faut repenser aussi nous
voilà où il prend part ou développe une
thèse sur la reconnaissance de ces
nouvelles formes de travail
c'est quoi les indicateurs de ses
nouvelles activités pour justement
permettre à l'individu de de s'engager
de s'impliquer de trouver du sens dans
ce qu'il fait n'est pas au travers
d'indicateurs qui sont complètement
inadaptés ou inappropriés et puis il ya
aussi ce qu'on appelle on qui peut être
aussi générateur de souffrance au
travail lorsque les outils sont
inadaptés ou inutiles par rapport au
projet du travail c'est à dire on a
encore une fois il ya des nouvelles
tâches qui ont été développés dans ce
travail distant mais les outils actuels
méthodes actuelles ne correspondent pas
à ce qui est fait ou alors elles sont
inadaptées c'est à dire que l'individu
doit clandestinement vous savez les
lélés comment les 38 mètres fut vendu en
tout cas les lélés les détourner merci
je trouvais le chercheur pour pouvoir
travailler normalement pour atteindre
ces objectifs le travail et en faisant
ça ils sortent et d'épée de damoclès
parce qu'il respecte pas la procédure
donc ça c'est aussi un stress permanent
ou alors utiliser plusieurs outils pour
travailler malgré tout il ya aussi
lorsqu'on donne des outils qui ne sont
pas cette fois-ci appropriée à
l'individu et au travail que je fais
c'est parce qu'on appelle manque
d'ergonomie de confort d'utilisation et
là du coup on va aussi faire un effort
intellectuel cognitif pour pouvoir
utiliser malgré tous ces outils
et puis un troisième niveau c'est
lorsque ces outils n'ont pas de sens par
rapport au travail que je fais il
s'incarne pas dans l'activité
c'est à dire il me demande de faire des
choses qui sont contraires à mes règles
de métier à mes critères de qualité à
mes valeurs professionnelles et à la il
ya un télescopage important quand par
exemple
effectivement on me dit bah voila tu va
utiliser un outil qui va permettre de
comme nous dans des enseignements
pouvoir identifier la participation des
élèves à distance sur vos cours on
mesure quoi encore une fois on mesure le
taux d'accès des élèves anoko mais pas
la qualité cet enseignement est du coup
de dé finir derrière ça des notations
des évaluations mais c'est pas ça mon
évaluation elle se fait pas sur des
indicateurs chiffrés c'est sûr
effectivement l'interaction les changes
mais ce n'est pas le nombre de fois où
s'est connecté c'est pas mes critères de
qualité d'évaluation royer et on
retrouve ça dans plein de métiers ou ce
que je fais parce qu'on parce qu'on me
demande dans mon travail et j'ai
l'impression aussi de faire un mauvais
travail à faire fort de faire un mauvais
travail
je me sens mauvais moi même et donc là
il ya aussi et un troisième aspect emile
il a également évoqué c'est cet aspect
également d'isolement de solitude
contrat se retrouvent dans ces nouvelles
formes de travail ou le collectif est
important puisque c'est une ressource à
l'individu ce sont des apports aussi
dans l'organisation du travail
je distinguerai deux notions l'isolément
la solitude
cet appareil d'isolement c'est quand
effectivement on est seul chez les soirs
et on n'arrive pas à ce corps d un
s'ajuster aux jo donc je rends compte de
mon activité en permanence donc j'ai une
sorte de méta travail où je dois
informer de ce que je fais en permanence
à tous les autres alors que caen et en
présentiel et bien des ce qu'on appelle
un peu la conscience mutualisé on voit
ce qui se passe à droite et à gauche et
je peux m'ajuster il est là il à ce
niveau là je peux elle apporte une et il
a avancé dans son projet je peux ma
forme et en open space 2 ou non etc où
j'ai pas besoin de parler discuter où il
ya des échanges un petit peu informel la
machine à café
donc ça c'est visuellement ou c'est là
justement la coordination sa gelée pas
je suis seul face à mon ordinateur
et puis la deuxième chose c'est la
solitude dans la solitude effectivement
c'est le sentiment de déréliction
c'est à dire le sentiment d'abandon je
ne peux plus compter sur les autres je
n'ai plus les moyens de me reposer sur
les autres de partage est finalement
peut-être des difficultés de travail et
que puisse résoudre ensemble ces
problématiques de travail et ça c'est
très important et je pense que quand on
parlait du manager du rôle du manager
s'est pas seulement recréer un espace
pour ce record données s'ajuster dans un
environnement particulier un peu
spécifique
puisqu'on est la distance mais aussi
permettre aux individus de parler du
travail qui ne va pas ce travail qui va
mal et qui fait mal et comment trouver
ensemble des solutions pour pouvoir
réorganiser une activité proposer des
outils
peut-être qu'on a trouvée par ailleurs
mais aussi être une redonner de la
légitimité à la parole des salariés dans
cette instance collective des
discussions pour que ça soit aussi
entendu par l'organisation
voilà je crois j'ai fait mes dix minutes
parce que je vois là merci l'excusé mois
exactement
merci merci monsieur je vais passer la
parole à monsieur stéphane pimbert de
l'hyène rs s'il veut prendre le micro
allez-y incident à la merci de m'avoir
informations sénatoriales le m'avoir
invité aujourd'hui pour cette recherche
et de sécurité pour la prévention des
activités parallèles et mais les
positionnements c'est sous les chauds et
là pour mission de l'appréhension budget
[Musique]
et surgissent les risques si cette
maison dit l'autre sur les chenilles et
fluide un billet sur les risques liés à
l'organisation et aux situations notre
milieu la prévention
les entreprises employeurs salariés je
sus les médecins américains je voulais
aujourd'hui les deux intervenants au
moins aussi en est d'ailleurs le christ
qui sont terrifiants du et en place
avant la crise sanitaire
si athènes une journée par semaine au
départ de journée dans ces conditions
ils sortent leur population de salariés
ne les mets tout mon entreprise de fil
je recevais les jeunes sur la situation
[Musique]
les deux visions le départ des deux
intervenants précédents
la guitare est aussi plus ce travail
partagé ciblons également on n'est pas
celle qui dit une à deux journées par
semaine
domicile par le seriez jours et puis
voilà on est sur site
le cosim il est ainsi que sur les
relations à la fois et je suis dans une
forme digitale et le lancement il y
avait dit qu'il est plutôt problématique
il a rassuré parce qu il me semblait
répondent pleinement compétents we7 dit
qu'à la sur-sollicitation et ils
comprennent pas une fois pas dans les
temps leurs voix et puis le autant le
télétravail avec la une chose qui est
elle a su comme un torrent dans
l'armoire quelques jours par semaine
quelques jours par mois
autant les nous sommes actuellement dans
une situation qui est complètement
différente sur le stand sur
l'intégration des nouveaux salariés et
sur la charge mentale des salariés qui
ont rapidement sauté les phares y penser
on luttera collective de travail
le rôle du management là
municipal avec réconciliation qui passe
la vie privée et puis l'organisation qui
s'installe à l'héroïsme de nude et le
travail on le verra notamment de la lisa
a parfaitement identifié le digital deux
grands types de risques posés par des
risques liés à l'activité physique des
troubles les spurs politique des
troubles oculaires ça a été ça et
éthiques et puis une inactivité physique
zélande arrêté on commence à identifier
réellement commun comme à risque et puis
à côté des réalités physiques ce qu'on
appelle le psycho sociaux et je m'en
vais un peu d'appréhension de services
notamment dans le cerveau psycho sociaux
en général c'est une absence de
régulation par le collectif lorsque le
télétravail effet de passementerie l'una
sens utile il dit et par là même une
bonne animation d'achat le temps a
changé les noms ont déjà une chose
d'important les personnes sollicitées au
bureau ça fait tuer notons finalement
c'est beaucoup moins bien lors que c'est
en des risques devrait lui avoir
conseillé de violences verbales ou
écrites qui sont à distance réelle qu'il
était peut-être moins enclins celles qui
le sont en tous les cas vers l'âme
écrite à distance
isolement voici deux intervenants ont
parlé et c'est bien entendu avec la de
séparation qui parce que les personnels
à des risques annuellement à l'équipe le
fait justement ces risques psychosociaux
la paire du khyber
aussi le métier qui chante avec digital
les champs de le management a changé le
mend jomo timité les différents
utilisateurs une chance le sens d'une
chanson et puis certains stades qui sont
par contre que à l'aise avec le
numérique ou mal équipés et ils
pourraient être développés les
sentiments l'explosion là aussi la
hausse il est ok donc ces risques d'une
part il est difficile au train par ce
choix les risques psychosociaux alors le
continent en temps pour nous dans ce
vent dans les feuilles sont les les dix
acteurs le dise le salarié je viens d'en
parler mais il ya aussi l'environnement
compte imiter le lorsqu'il est lorsqu'il
ya un travail à avoir sur i en cette
période de crise la mi temps avec ce
téléphone que j'avais avant si il ne
regarde l'âge manquons s'imiter déjà
vivre le multi d'animer d'animer son
petit mais sans physique avec des
régulations informel qui sont souvent
dégradés avec park sur investissement de
la nature sollicitation d'un oubli car
c'est de l'argent qui est différent
qu'il est là maintenant proximité en
avant de l'environnement possibilités du
mal ont aussi limité
qu'ils soient présents et qu'ils soient
les gouttes
le chalet membres sont nuls ça c'est pas
forcément simple pour le management de
proximité qui lui-même le lit et le lit
parfois difficilement s'amuser sur lui
une lourde charge mentale régulièrement
de l'ensemble devant l'objectif de façon
donc le voir même plus longue et
l'équipe son sursis ses environs
et puis le seul devant il a il a
toujours alors en les moyens aussi bien
l'information comment il est et vous
intervenant à parler management par
objectifs le mât n'a pas d'objectif dans
une entreprise c'est quelque chose qui
est complètement différent le management
en présentiel ou le manager le manager
est présent d'avoir régulièrement
exemple ici président le ça vaille est
celle ya des choses qui suppose par
exemple une formation forte
on ne m'a pas d'un madame hostilités et
des salariés elle n'a même pas été
difficile pour l'australie samedi pour
la nature le manager avait l'habitude
d'avoir c'est finalement les salariés au
moins vont pouvoir échanger avec eux et
dans nos petits à l'espagne qui avait un
an qu'à nantes notamment dans les cas de
difficultés ou sur l'avancement des
sujets donc pas si un objectif qui est
l'aspect l'émotion normal dans cette
section qui est basané qui suppose une
formation on peut le voir aussi bien du
de l'engagement que les salariés à la
même formation
mais ça suppose oui les deux lunes
idéologiques les les
les érections elle son dentier travail a
évidemment été gâté five c'est souvent
des désaccords entre eux puisqu'ils ont
mis qu'il en est en place à condat zone
attire régulièrement une émotion une
l'impression d'y l'élection de l'équipe
et puis parfois ça a été dit aussi la
passion d'un attachement sans risque
excuse pas travailler l'aspect qui est
très important nous d'en face et a
fortiori dans ce massif c'est le
collectif déjà parlé c'est d'avoir
important la santé mentale en entreprise
et qui a tendance à ceux à se déliter
l'attention que l'on travaille à une
thèse mais bien pensé et l'espace de
convivialité qui sont calmes et plus et
salariés qui ne se rencontrent en plus
le collectif et donc plus équilibré les
échanges en plus plus les mêmes hallyday
oued à manager charismatique en
présentiel le devient beaucoup moins si
le télétravail ne vient pensif et très
très très très régulier autre aspect le
collectif il aborde une vanité dans les
échelons
lorsqu'on est dans une période de leur
enchaînement de télétravail un ou deux
jours par semaine est vaste
mettons un jour par semaine au bureau et
gens peuvent continuer à échanger
lorsqu'on est dans le cas actuel et
télétravail nancy cette valeur ajoutée
qui n'est les échanges entre les entrées
seriez là commence à disparaître très
très très largement
donc par rapport à ce moment alors bien
entendu les serveuses et partie des
éléments de négation notamment des
documents que j'avais reçues via
invendus de l'employeur il doit
s'occuper de cet aspect du théâtre avant
des risques identifiés physique et
psychologique qui doit s'occuper des
petites banques et il doit réaliser dans
ce qu'on appelle document guide des
risques il doit identifier ces risque
évident qu'ils sont si bien l'église de
cuisine que des risques psychosociaux
téléspectateurs sur l'oml identifié a
renvoyé la dent qu'un du document
annulation des risques en vendée et dans
l'aveyron ce document doit l'être exit
également connaissait pas simplement
quelle star ici aussi lorsque les
historiens sont en général il peut avoir
cette actualisation et qui doit
identifier va identifier et derrière et
on voit surtout reposé l'information ce
document de la chaîne lci c'est un socle
pour la prévention dans l'entreprise il
est vrai bien figurer en séries il doit
être bien fait pour identifier les
actions qui seront des actions de
prévention pour éviter c'est thierry
donc ce monsieur pimbert on va continuer
le tour de table pour que chacun des
participants s'expriment et ouvrir après
la voie aux questions donc je vous
remercie je vais passer la parole au
professeur de witte qui je le rappelle
est président a sauté française de
médecine du travail
merci monsieur plein mais on reviendra
sur les sujets que vous avez évoqué
certains mouvements et merci aussi de de
m'avoir invité tout d'abord je vous
présente toutes mes excuses de d'être
resté à mon domicile
mais comme je l'avais indiqué
effectivement ça tombait juste au moment
où la société française de médecine
travail dont je suis l'actuel président
a organisé ses journées scientifiques et
que c'est m'était difficile d'aller
faire un aller-retour mais que je suis
enseignant chercheur à l'université de
brest
et donc c'était difficile de faire un
aller-retour pour être là pour reprendre
les journées scientifiques qui se font à
la première fois d'ailleurs aussi en
100% virtuel je peux vous dire que au
niveau stress son jeu c'est un petit pas
ce que c'est 2 d'arriver à ce nouveau
mal de fonctionnement et d'organisation
alors bon peut-être quelques mois sur la
société donc la société française
décidée travail était pas très ancienne
puisqu'elle elle a 35 ans à peu près
maintenant mais elle s'occupe bien sûr
aussi de d'essayer de faire le point sur
les situations et bien sûr le nouvelle
organisation du travail font partie des
réflexions que n'ont pu avoir et pour
lequel nous avons fait certaines
recommandations
il faut peut-être aussi distingué ce que
nous avions demandé ce qu'il y est on va
dire télétravail le ce serait qu'on
parle beaucoup de télétravail j'en
parlerai bien sûr aussi mais la question
c'est est une nouvelle organisation du
travail et dans les nouvelles
organisations du travail mes collègues
en particulier de psychologues du
travail en ont parlé là sur
l'intensification du travail mais il ya
aussi
moi je voulais peut-être insisté sur le
côté de déshumanisation en exemple d'une
entreprise de vous savez de vente à
distance
quand pourvoi les conditions de travail
avec des lunettes connectés qui vous
oblige à vous déplacer sans avoir un
seul moment de réflexion quand ça va etc
c'est vrai que là aussi il ya quelque
chose peut-être à se pencher et nous en
tant que médecin du travail bien sûr on
est en charge essentiellement de la
prévention primaire et je reviendrai
peut-être là-dessus d'ailleurs quand on
abordera la nba l'accord national
interprofessionnel peut-être le rôle la
proposition de projet de loi aussi
puisque vous aviez demandé de deux d'y
réfléchir parce que notre rôle c'est
quand même essentiellement de faire de
la prévention primaire même si
maintenant effectivement dans nos
missions
il y aura aussi la prévention de la
désinsertion donc là c'est quelque chose
pour nous qui est absolument fondamental
qu'on a parfois du mal à à les
appréhender
là aussi je remercie tous nos collègues
de l'équipe pluridisciplinaire et en
particulier des intervenants en
prévention des risques professionnels
vont faire partie
les psychologues du travail alors pour
le train télétravail c'est encore autre
chose puisque là on va remettre à
domicile dans les autres organisations
aussi du du travail je voulais revenir
/ par exemple si les open space qui fut
des nouvelles organisations de travail
je crois pas en avoir entendu parler par
mes prédécesseurs mais qui en termes de
monsieur travail nous pose aussi
beaucoup de beaucoup de soucis alors le
médecin du travail il est là
effectivement utilisés pour faire de la
prévention pour faire de la prévention
de la désinsertion donc plutôt déjà
tardivement et puis là je vais me
positionner en tant que profitant de ce
travail aussi président du comité
régional de reconnaissance de maladie
professionnelle dans le bout de la
chaîne qui est malheureusement quand la
prévention a échoué et qu'on arrive à la
à la déclassant maladies
professionnelles il ya eu une longue
discussion il ya quelques années de
savoir s'il fallait faire un tableau
fameux mot de burnout avait été évoqué
on avait rappelé que c'était une maladie
que c'était juste effectivement une
association de symptômes de syndrome
mais en tout cas pour l'instant la face
temps de faire reconnaître ces
pathologies
c'est de passer par ces commissions
régionales de pathologies
professionnelles vont être des
professionnels alors dans les documents
que je pourrais vous faire parvenir si
vous les aviez déjà il y avait
effectivement à ce qui avait été publié
le dernier rapport d'adp de décembre
2020 sur la caisse nationale d'assurance
maladie et d reconnaissance en maladie
professionnelle
on voit bien sur le rapport de gestion
une augmentation considérable des
reconnu des déclarations et ensuite
éventuellement des des reconnaissances
effectivement en maladie professionnelle
avec un pic qui a été en partir de 2013
parce que les conditions d'accès au
système de reconnaissance ont été
modifiés et ont permis que beaucoup de
dossier qui jusque là étaient bloquées
présent damman puisse arriver jusqu'à
nous alors avec des disparités quand
même régionales parce que effectivement
ces responsables des consultation de
pathologie professionnelle est souvent
qu'ils sont anti sièges donc dans les
commissions régionales de ma vie
professionnelle
on n'a pas tous la même sensibilité moi
je suis par exemple malades de formation
et donc du coup il a fallu que je
m'adapte effectivement à cette nouvelle
entité qui étaient les maladies maladies
psychiques et que quand l'appel
classiquement les risques psychosociaux
et en même temps je regarde c'est le
tableau que je me propose de vous
envoyer on voit bien par exemple que en
2019 on a une énorme proportion de le
syndrome dépressif qui ont été déclarées
et reconnues au titre de ces deux
étaient donc là il ya un véritablement
un témoin de cette souffrance qui ont
été signalés par mes collègues
psychologue du travail donc pour moi
c'est quelque chose absolument important
je suis également
vous savez depuis maintenant deux ans
l'expertisé scientifique elle à
l'origine de l'occupation des
modifications notables aux
professionnels a été confiée à laon 16
qui a créé un groupe de travail
donc nous travaillons sur effectivement
cessé ces sujets là mais pour l'instant
en tout cas on reste on n'a pas été
sollicité sur les risques psychosociaux
et donc le système de reconnaissance
ça reste quand même celui des c2 et
rappelle des comités régionaux de
reconnaissance de pathologie
professionnelle
pour eux entre temps et laisser la place
à la discussion
juste un mot sur quand même nom que
donne la réforme de la santé au travail
telle qu'elle est actuellement à kindi
nous inquiète beaucoup puisque nous
avons écrit un certain nombre de
réflexions de la société française en se
basant bien sûr sur notre expertise nous
de d'enseignants d'universitaires dans
le domaine mais on est quand même très
très inquiet de la perte un petit peu
d'expérience du médecin du travail qui
risque de se passer avec la mise en
place d des praticiens correspondant qui
ne seront des médecins généralistes
[Musique]
avait pour l'instant pas de formation
dessus et pour en revenir au télétravail
déjà nous médecins du travail nous avons
beaucoup de mal à aller chez les
individus quand ils sont chez eux et la
gueule mais pas assez sur leur landi
cette perte de frontière entre la vie
personnelle la vie professionnelle avec
son environnement qui affluent cette
sensation souvent que les employeurs en
que quand quelqu'un est en télétravail à
son domicile
bailly travaille pas et donc tout ce qui
a été dit sur la façon de seuil et de
quantifier
si le sa caméra est connecté s'il tape
sur son clavier souvent answer to c est
cette difficulté que et les en payant en
peul finalement à son domicile d'un
salarié ne travaille pas comme s'il
était dans son bureau là et nous laisser
travail on peut pas aller sur place chez
l'individu avec toutes les difficultés
économiques aussi c'est parce que autant
on peut donner des préconisations très
salée travail sur l'ergonomie du poste
de travail du siège etc
quand décès à son domicile vous donnez
les préconisations peut-être sur
l'ordinateur a été ramené sur le ciel
sur les repose pieds c'est l'élément qui
liquide quand même en influencer sur la
souris ça ce sera impossible
et si en plus ce seront les encore perdu
un peu plus avec ces praticiens
correspondant nous sommes quand même
considérablement inquiet sur l'avenir de
notre de notre profession voilà je peux
être arrêté là elle me tiens à votre
disposition pour la suite de maîtrise et
visionnaire six professeurs merci de
votre intervention madame messieurs
merci à chacun d'avoir initié le débat
donc je vais je vais passer la parole en
premier lieu aux rapporteurs en
commençant par madame berthet et puis
ensuite dans l'assistance j'ai une haute
et déjà des questions dont on le fera la
suite merci beaucoup président eh bien
monsieur le professeur de vide je vais
rebondir tout de suite sur ce que vous
ce par quoi vous venez de terminer
et justement cette barrière du domicile
pour la santé au travail des
recommandations pour des standards
installations du salarié à son domicile
donc sont en cours de réalisation
j'imagine qu'ils sont coupés vous faites
des préconisations dans ce sens y at il
de nouveau référentiel qui se met en
place pour ces évaluations concernant la
santé du travail du salarié à son
domicile
également il était question par votre
prédécesseur monsieur pimbert du
document unique d'évaluation des risques
bon vous avez commencé à nous en parler
j'aimerais peut-être que vous ayez un
peu plus loin savez vous s'il y a des
justement beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont
réévalué
ces risques et qui insiste à présent sur
ce télétravail que nous connaissons et
qui va en s'accentuant et que même une
fois que la crise sera terminée nous le
savons continuera à être pratiquée et
c'est là justement que je me tourne vers
madame vert et monsieur mobile et
chaumont pour vous y at il un drop de
jour idéal à ne pas dépasser en
télétravail justement par rapport à tout
ce que vous avez pointé
concernant les risques psychosociaux
dernière question très rapide voyez vous
une différence dans la difficulté
ou au contraire dans l'adaptation selon
les tranches d'âge pour les salariés ou
les managers dans ce ce télétravail ces
nouveaux modes de travail de façon
générale merci merci martin comme il ya
des questions pour chacun d'entre vous
on va reprendre les interventions en
commençant par le professeur de 8 si
vous voulez je vous donne la parole
j'ai eu 1 10 ou si vous avez eu un trou
justement ma liberté s'adressait à moi
c'est ca des difficultés du télétravail
sans lui le monde de suite de renforcer
sa question précise le journal
oui donc précisément sur c'est une
question plutôt sur les nouveaux
référentiels concernant la santé au
travail sur des évaluations justement
cette difficulté par rapport au domicile
sur les préconisations fait les
recommandations standard que vous pouvez
peut-être vous mettez en oeuvre
actuellement j'imagine pour une
installation a minima du travailleur à
son domicile
la société française en elle même n'a
pas fait de recommandations à je pense
que c'est plutôt du domaine de nos
collègues de dindonneau miné par contre
à l'occasion du premier confinement
aussi nos collègues de messi le travail
se sont retrouvés eux mêmes en
télétravail à aa
oui ciel alors parfois avec des
conditions assez assez difficile parce
que pour des raisons on va dire voir
mettre les gens au chômage partiel
certains directeurs de centres de
services de santé au travail à découper
carrément l'accès à la messagerie et
donc les à la fois les entreprises
essayé de contacter leur médecin du
travail et ne pouvait pas avoir de
réponse puisque le travail n'y avait pas
là
la solution est donc on avait nos
niveaux de la société française de
baisers et il travaille fait le 15 avril
2020 anne avides justement relatives à
la façon d'essayer de travailler dans
les meilleures conditions pour faire
téléconsultation santé au travail et
j'ai moi-même diriger un travail de
thèse ensuite sur un médiateur qui a
montré un peu les difficultés qu'elle
avait rencontré aussi les médecins du
travail pour pouvoir faire cet été les
consultations avec la difficulté que moi
j'ai déjà c'est qu'on n'est pas tous
bien relié au réseau au réseau internet
que vous vous êtes vous venez de le dire
selon notre âge on n'a pas tous les
mêmes des affinités vers les nouveaux
les nouvelles technologies internet etc
donc c'est assez compliqué mais en
termes d'ergonomie de nous mêmes nous
n'avons pas effectivement fait encore de
préconisation sur ce sujet c'est vrai
que la télé
le télétravail c'est tellement développé
brutalement que nous n'avons pas eu le
lot casion de vraiment nous pencher
dessus et je dois reconnaître que dans
cette période de sanitaires que nous
vivons un peu eux disent ils l'essentiel
des réflexions actuellement des sociétés
françaises seront concernés par la
gestion de l'épidémie
ds ça qu'on va vous intéresse merci
professeur monsieur pimbert donc sur le
document unique et son appréciation face
nord merci madame c'est le document
d'évaluation des risques
je vais répondre devant deux parties
votre question
les entreprises qui font habituellement
le document d'évaluation des risques de
leurs couleurs pour le roller sic on
nous le pensons je pense à lui
avec la crise sanitaire d'une part et
avec le travail kenya lac islamique avec
le télétravail est lié à l'accessibilité
on refait cette évaluation des risques
ils l'ont adapté en bois une fois à la
crise solitaire au risque selon et
respecte le protocole d'ailleurs je
régler les derniers mystères victoria
précise que ce sont des risques douanes
mise à jour
d'autre part cela les entreprises qui
ont fait ce docu donc fait ce document
d'évalution amérique qui le font
régulièrement avec derrière bien entendu
en action ont mis en place des actions
de prévention qu'ils soient moins vrai
et qui qui sont adaptés à la situation
est donc la 7e à ce changement en
relation la difficulté elle est plus
dans le nombre de l'entreprise qui en
france font réellement le document
d'évaluation des risques parce que je
potier d'en avoir en tête exactement le
chiffre mais je pense que la lnd dernier
dont j'ai entendu parler et d'environ 5
% des entreprises qui faisait réellement
document d'évalution la lys il pour une
partie le faisait par partie de la
nation et fanny non pas de façon
préventive avec des murs action donc
pourrait vendre les entreprises qu'ils
font de la bio fédération mise à jour
avec la crise sanitaire alors pas
difficultés je pense personnellement
d'évaluer de nouveaux risques est réduit
et nouvelle façon
il était la difficulté de l'entreprise
qu'ils n'ont pas l'habitude de faire ou
qui ne font pas régulièrement seul sur
la pratique du management
merci merci on va continuer notre tour
en concernant le rythme idéal en
présentiel ou en distance monsieur
bobillier chaud je pense qu'on peut pas
imposer un rythme de manière unilatérale
et péremptoire de manière d'être est
descendante aux personnes en revanche je
pense qu'il est nécessaire effectivement
d'offrir un espace où la personne un
espace et un temps la personne puisse
revenir parce que l'attachement à
l'entreprise attachons entreprises
physique al la présence physique c'est
aussi le sentiment d'appartenance à
l'organisation et de protections et de
reconnaissance on y revient aussi et
puis il ya aussi ces lieux ou encore une
fois on parle de déshumanisation tout à
l'heure de l'activité de l'activité ou
des liens par l'entremise de cette
technologie on travaille certes plus
ensemble à distance mais seul quand même
devant son ordinateur
et du coup il ya une nécessité il ya un
besoin des salariés de revenir le rythme
de commandes
je pense que ça soit être discuté à
partir de l'activité parce qu'il ya
certaines activités qui nécessitent de
revenir et de discuter sur des choses
profondes
on parle de encore une fois de qualité
du difficulté du travail et puis ou de
deux problématiques plus personnel mais
on est en face à face
et puis d'autres reuters ça peut être
tenus à distance mais ça c'est une
régulation des règles de métier qui doit
être redéfinie et je veux parler à
l'heure de ce cet espace de travail que
majeur à mettre en place et pas
simplement dire ça va ça va pas mais
comment peut-on faire pour que ce sortir
et redéfinir c'est en présence et puis
j'avais aussi une autre chose à dire
c'était par rapport aux 6 à la
configuration
à mon avis il n'y a rien
pire des maux l'hybride mode hybride
c'est ce qu'on vit actuellement c'est à
dire où il ya une partie des personnes
en présence et l'autre à distance et on
voit bien que c'est pas la même
dynamique c'est pas les échanges parce
que chacun dans un espace à système
social de vie un monde social qui est le
sien et donc on a aussi des difficultés
à pouvoir recréer un espace commun ce
qui affecte aussi ou amplifier encore
ces difficultés de relations d'échangé
puis de le communauté de partage voilà
mesdames vers votre sentiment sur ce
problème de rythme oui j'aurais tendance
à répondre que non il n'ya pas de nombre
de jour idéal de télétravail en fait ça
dépend vraiment de la culture de
l'entreprise de la manière dont il est
accompagné la manière dont il est
déployé
mais aussi et surtout des contraintes et
des besoins à la fois lié à l'activité à
la tâche qu'on doit réaliser aux
salariés qui a aussi ses propres
ressources et ses propres contraintes
mais aussi aux équipes parce que le
télétravail rarement penser au plan du
collectif c'est souvent une négociation
entre le salarié et son manager entre le
salarié et son organisation de travail
mais on réfléchit rarement modalités de
travail en fonction des besoins et des
contraintes de l'équipe ou du service
et c'est là où il ya peut-être un
travail à faire ça dépend également des
contraintes évidemment regagné propre à
l'organisation de travail
ce que je voulais ajouter c'est d'abord
il faut pas penser uniquement même si
c'est le plus fréquent le télétravail
uniquement au domicile il ya d'autres
formes de télétravail qui existe on peut
imaginer fait ça existe aussi le thé le
télétravail entière lieu dédié dans des
bureaux satellites voilà donc ça c'est
aussi il faut avoir aussi ça en tête et
puis je pense que le définir le
télétravail le plus adapté et le plus
approprié donc à une organisation une
équipe un service ça va dépendre aussi
des conditions de travail lorsqu'on
n'est pas en télétravail
parce que le télétravail en tout cas tel
qu'il existe à l'heure actuelle et ce à
rebondir a aussi sur ce que disait
monsieur de vie tout à l'heure et très
souvent associées et je le disais dans
mon exposé au départ ce qui nous
en tant que psychologue du travail et
des organisations c'est que souvent les
télétravailleurs explique qu'ils sont
mieux en télétravail plus hauts cadres
qui peuvent davantage se concentrer
parce qu'au quotidien
ils sont dans des environnements de
travail marquées par des nuisances
sonores par un climat social de stress
et donc dans des environnements que même
juge délétère et pour eux ils apprécient
le télétravail mais c'est aussi de fuite
d'un environnement d'un lieu de travail
dans lequel ils ne souhaitent plus ou
moins travaillé en tout cas et c'est
souvent quand s'est associé comme le
disait monsieur de witte à des espaces
ouverts open space plus récemment flex
office des open space qui ont été
déployés sous prétexte de d'amélioration
de la collaboration qui en fait ont
favorisé le contrôle par les pairs des
flex office qui ont été déployés sous
prétexte d'agilité de l'activité et du
travail en équipe
mais qui en fait pose la question de
l'appropriation de l'espace dont on sait
qu'ils jouent sur la performance et le
bien-être des personnes qui pose aussi
la question du rapport au travail à
l'organisation de travail parce qu'on
peut s'interroger sur la place qu'on
occupe au sein d'une structure dans
laquelle on n'a plus sa place
physiquement merci michel calvet merci
je le président je voudrais remercier
l'ensemble des intervenants
effectivement c'est très intéressant par
rapport aux risques de deux conflits
d'opposition qui ont été évoqués dans
l'inventaire des risques tout à l'heure
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un risque de
fracture génération c'est-à-dire de
départ de personnes qu'ils soient ou de
vente et de départ de personnes qu'ils
soient proches de l'âge de la retraite
et qui se sentent un peu dépassé par
l'ensemble de ces évolutions est ce
qu'il ya là un risque vis-à-vis des
seniors je me demandais aussi sur la
question de la prévention des risques
psychosociaux
est-ce que les sujets sont bien
maîtrisés aujourd'hui parce qu'on voit
bien que là il ya un impact est un
risque majeur sur les risques
psychosociaux contenu 2
l'ensemble des des risques que vous avez
inventorié tout à l'heure est ce qu'on
est capable de bien appréhender sans et
comment peut-on l'interdît dans un
contexte où une partie des travailleurs
seraient dans des lieux tiers y compris
par rapport au risque addictif divers
que l'on peut identifier
ordinairement mais qui peuvent
s'accentuer parce que n'étant plus vu
dans un contexte professionnel où on est
une si tu es bien est-ce qu'il ya pas un
risque sur ces risques a dit un
dictionnaire majeur et aussi par rapport
à cela
est-ce que vous avez évoqué l'évolution
phase d'évolution des métiers
effectivement il n'ya pas que le
télétravail à domicile il ya aussi les
espaces de coworking par exemple dont on
voit bien qu'ils sont en train de se
développer un peu partout et ça peut
être effectivement une solution pour
lutter contre l' isolement
alors est-ce que cela ne risque pas
d'entraîner une évolution dans le
rapport aux salariés c'est à dire est ce
que le salarié ne risque pas finalement
de devenir à sous traitants et donc
étant éventuellement autonome par
rapport à cette distance qu'il prend
avec avec le travail et l'entreprise et
donc voilà pour ce qui concerne
l'identification des risques
est ce que vous pensez qu'il est
nécessaire que l'on légifère pour mieux
cadrer les choses ou pensez-vous que le
devoir de prévention des entreprises et
de l'ensemble des acteurs professionnels
suffisant pour pouvoir apporter une
réponse adaptée à l'ensemble des risques
qui ont été identifiés on a évoqué
effectivement l'évolution enfin le
télétravail les open space etc
mais il ya bien d'autres métiers dans
lesquels numérique fait une apparition
considérable et un impact important dans
tous les métiers je dirais parce que un
commerçant il a besoin du numérique
maintenant pour savoir s'il y avait le
marchandises en stock
un artisan a besoin du numérique pour
pouvoir dans le bâtiment par exemple
concevoir son travail
identifier comment dirais-je la femme
des besoins jallet de vie un industriel
aujourd'hui alors que l'on parle de
robotisation accrue dans la société bien
ça veut dire transformation des métiers
aussi pour l'ensemble des ouvriers vers
de la production vers la gestion de deux
robots dans la logistique c'est pareil
il y a aussi des évolutions
considérables est ce que est ce que cela
présente aussi des risques par rapport à
l'ensemble des professionnels et pas
seulement vis-à-vis des sites et les
travailleurs puis dernière question est
ce que le développement du numérique
ainsi va entraîner un déplacement des
lieux de vie des gens je veux dire par
là qu'aujourd'hui on sait que la
population est concentrée revers à
proximité de là où sont importés à peu
près 10 que finalement c'est pas un
moyen pour pouvoir amener les gens à
bourges ou ailleurs parce que
effectivement on a parfois des
inquiétudes sur son territoire je passe
après c'est aussi est-ce que c'est pas
un moyen de faire valoir un meilleure
répartition de la population sur le
territoire
merci michel m'ont beaucoup de questions
donc écouter on va prendre un ordre
géographique
madame vert si vous voulez commencer et
on va la suivre
je sais pas si tu es arrivé à répondre à
toutes les questions mais comme on est
plusieurs donc sur le sur l'appréhension
des risques et notamment la question des
risques d'addiction effectivement il
faut travailler là dessus en entreprise
et ça passe nécessairement par de
nouvelles normes aussi des règles
d'usagé la régulation des usages et là
encore il faut absolument s'intéresser
au travail réel comme je disais tout à
l'heure et aux contraintes et besoins
ressources spécifiques un aux salariés
aux équipes aux organisations à le faire
de manière arbitraire l'élu beaucoup
d'échecs en la matière sur la question
par exemple de la déconnexion
notamment parce qu'on a développé des
dispositifs techniques par exemple ou en
couple la messagerie qui sont pas
toujours adaptés en fait à la réalité du
travail donc il faut vraiment là aussi
faire du sur mesure en fonction d'eux
des salariés des équipes et de
l'organisation sur la question du
territoire alors c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup parlé des risques associés au
déploiement du télétravail
en particulier il ya aussi des bénéfices
bien sûr associé au télétravail des
bénéfices en termes d'articulation entre
vie professionnelle et vie privée
c'est pas toujours en tout cas le
résultat final n'est pas toujours dans
le conflit et dans l'empiètement de la
vie professionnelle sur la vie privée
il ya aussi des télétravailleurs d'été
les travailleuses qui arrive à déployer
alors c'est pas sans mal c'est au
travers de négociations et de
discussions justement avec l'entourage
professionnel comme avec l'entourage
familial avec qui il faut négocier la
question des espaces et des temps dédié
au travail et ceux dédiés aux arts
travaille avec qui il faut établir de
nouvelles règles notamment quand on a
des enfants en bas âge pour pas qu'ils
viennent déranger la personne qui
travaille en même temps pour pouvoir
aussi prendre le temps de bénéficier du
télétravail et pouvoir y consacrer plus
de temps ou à des moments différents
mais il ya aussi des bénéfices
effectivement en termes de répartition
sur le territoire donc là c'est moi mon
domaine de spécialité mais ça implique
aussi que les personnes peuvent gagner
en qualité de vie notamment
effectivement éviter un maximum les
trajets qui peuvent être longues quand
on est dans des métropoles et puis
bénéficié d'être plus ouverts de dodin
domicile donc plus plus large et d'avoir
donc une qualité de vie familiale et
sociale qui puisse être améliorée
donc ça c'est des effets qui peuvent
être positifs associés au télétravail
peut être juste sur la fracture
générationnelle
je pense que c'est enfin je sais pas si
il y a fracturé en tout cas
effectivement des différences qui
peuvent être imaginées qui sont pas
nécessairement dû uniquement à la
génération c'est difficile de dissocier
l'âge la génération l'expérience aussi
professionnelle le fait d'être et
expérimentés ou novices qui est pas
toujours associé à l'âge il y avait
effectivement des personnes seniors
qu'on pourrait qualifier de seniors ou
des personnes qui sont plus avancés dans
l'âge qui peuvent se sentir moins
efficace et moins compétentes dans
l'utilisation des technologies
mais en même temps ce sont aussi celles
qui sont les plus expérimentés et qui
une fois formés peuvent peut-être mieux
exploiter ses technologies au mieux les
détourner pour qu'elle profite en fait à
leurs activités professionnelles autres
aussi représentation qui est parfois
erronées on imagine que parce que les
jeunes générations utilisent bouquet
beaucoup ces outils technologiques
ils seront plus performants pour les
utiliser dans le cadre professionnel
or les travaux ont tendance à montrer
que c'est pas si simple de transférer
des compétences dans le domaine de vie à
l'autre et qu'on peut être très
performant dans le domaine personnel
tout en étant très peu performante dans
le domaine professionnel
lesieu bobillier shlomo si vous voulez
pour rebondir sur la question de la des
déterminismes générationnel quelque part
sur la capacité à s'approprier cette
transformation digitale ou ces nouvelles
formes de travail
je pense qu'effectivement il faut faire
attention et c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'obsolescence des compétences ou la
caducité des compétences c'est-à-dire il
ya une représentation généralités on
avait fait une recherche au niveau
européen pour voir comment les avec
rocade qui est l'organisation syndicale
européenne à qui regroupe toutes les
grandes grands partenaires sociaux et
qui avait montré s'était enfin on avait
montré que effectivement et c'est un
constat parmi les entreprises qui à 50
ans on considère que ça n'a rien n'est
plus apte à faire face à ces nouvelles
formes de travail ne faut pas investir
sur lui et le problème qui se pose c'est
pas un une transformation mais c'est ça
aussi qui est nouveau et qui est
important c'est la succession des
transformations c'est la régularité
l'arabité voir la brutalité avec elsa
riz c'est à dire qu'on est par n'associe
pas les salariés on les applique pas
alors que comme on l'évoquait ils ont
une expérience une expérience du travail
de l'activité du métier les clients ils
peuvent permettre de
construire mais quand effectivement
c'est des transformations qui arrivent
sans cesse de manière rapide
non seulement ça exige une grande à
stable rand
je dirais déstabilisation cognitives ou
mentale puisque du coup il ya un
investissement course d apprendre à
apprendre ces outils qui reconfigurent
complètement le métier aussi une grande
déstabilisation professionnelle puisque
on arrive dans une sorte de précarité
professionnelle c'est qu'on n'arrive
plus à maîtriser l'outil qui nous permet
de travailler et donc effectivement
c'est là où ça y est le général à une
comment une création de souffrance au
travail par la difficulté a été un outil
qui change sans cesse et alors qu'ils
ont une expérience
on le disait là par rapport à des jeunes
une expérience du métier moi je me
souviens d'une intervention qu'on avait
fait je les ingénieurs et là je voudrais
justement apporter un second sujet moi
je vois que et on est servi dans des
grandes entreprises sur les pertes
connexion assure connexion hors travail
comment essayer de rendre visible ce
travail qui se déroule en dehors et
pouvoir leur est pas trier pour prendre
les bonnes décisions et faire comprendre
aux décideurs que les mesures qu'ils
prennent les outils qu'ils mettent en
place ont des répercussions sur la vie
personnelle la vie sociale des gens
qu'on essaie de mettre sans visibilité
donc on utilise des méthodes un peu
innovante pour le faire je me souviens
qu'avec les services de centrales de
séquences d'organisation il nous aide
on a beaucoup de difficulté à faire
parler les gens sur cette souffrance sur
ses difficultés parce qu'il faut public
ce sont des cadres et par leur statut
c'est des gens qui doivent être qu'ils
doivent tenir qu'il va porter le message
qu'ils doivent
comment porter les transformations qui
doivent s'adapter s'ajuster en
permanence donc toujours tout va bien
par des questionnaires par des udc quand
on va sur le terrain quand on regarde ce
que justement l'activité quand ça ne va
pas et là on voit que des points de
blocage du coup effectivement je pense
que il ya cette idée de de pouvoir
rendre un peu content de cette
difficulté travaillé par rapport aux
seniors donc c'était l'exemple que je
vous ai donné je me souviens que les
seniors étaient ceux qui juraient
lemieux fin des cas les plus
expérimentés l'afflux de mails par
rapport aux jeunes qui arrivent et
puisque nous qu'on est dans une
entreprise on sait que lorsqu'on reçoit
un message
parfois c'est ça vient d'un destinataire
qui dit les choses plus intéressantes
voire même sur le
le sujet du mail donc on arrive à trier
simplement par une première lecture
alors que les jeunes eux ils prennent
tous ils intègrent tous et du coup ça
crée une charge de travail très
importante
on le voit c'est qu'ils ont une
expérience ils ont un collectif ils ont
un réseau de connaissances informel de
l'entreprise qui permet effectivement
parfois de gérer justement les les
limites de la technologie dans le
travail donc attention et pas s'en
séparer parce qu'ils ont des compétences
et des connaissances important la
deuxième question c'est est sûre les le
développement des tic sur le travail sur
les métiers effectivement vous
connaissez 7,7 cette recherche et
demande dans ce bordel des bénédictins
qui qui disait que près 43 % des emplois
disparaîtraient avec l'arrivée des
technologies émergentes
alors c'est ce chiffre a été beaucoup
critiquée et maintenant selon le cd et
le conseil d'orientation pour l'emploi
ont entre 9 et 14 % des emplois actuels
qui disparaîtrait mais il ya une chose
qui est sûre c'est que tous les emplois
comme vous le disiez seront affectées
d'une manière ou d'une autre par
l'arrivée de cette technologie et la
problématique qui se pose c'est jusqu'où
va aller ces technologies c'est à dire
est ce que j y aura un remplacement
partiel ou total de l'activité
quand c'est par siège et justement c'est
quoi ce partiel c'est ce qui représente
le coeur du métier c'est-à-dire ce qui
donne du sens à mon travail c'est ce qui
me donne envie de venir au travail de me
dépenser pour me travail voire de
souffrir parfois parce que pour ce trail
parce qu'il a du sens mais si on extrait
on dépossède l'individu de 7,2 cette
commande ce coeur de cet intérêt et on
le donnait au système c'est à dire que
l'individu devient le l'assistant de la
technique est pas la technologie qu'elle
vient d'assister et c'est vraiment
toutes ces questions qu'on a
or là dans les transformations digital
qu'on accompagne ou qu'on observe on
voit qu'il ya l'idée que c'est la
technologie qui est la solution est pas
une solution possible bien sûr de
déterminisme technologique on pense que
effectivement pour tout problème toute
difficulté la technologie va résoudre
toutes les questions qui se posent donc
on impose sans concertation sans
conciliation avec les salariés et donc
ça a eu de ces variables d'ajustement
lundi vis à lui de faire l'effort pour
s'adapter et l'intégrer et ça c'est
vraiment le gros problème qui génère
encore une fois des problématiques de
souffrance parce qu'on ne se reconnaît
pas parce que l'outil n'est pas adapté à
son activité parce qu'il est père de
nommer
parce que nous demande de faire des
choses contraires à nos valeurs et ses
dires je reviens petit peu ce que
j'évoquais du talent merci monsieur
pimbert donc sur revenir sur le document
d'évaluation des risques et son aspect
obligatoire ou pas parfaite de documents
de la série ce qui est déjà au méga
thoiras une figure dans le code du
travail
les articles r car en termes suivants
les ont mis d'accord il a été créé en
2001 donc il est déjà remis d'avoir ce
qu'il faut c'est que les entreprises
prennent conscience de l'importance à la
voilà centre travail même si nous devons
partir de plaisance
consciente mais aussi du rôle de cette
nocturne et nationaliste sebbar
simplement un document où les statines
un document qui en vue d'identifier les
risques et d'essayer de les éviter à
travers des actions mission identifier
et donc faire de la prévention
donc pas besoin d'une loi sur la
surévaluation des risques y compris sur
l'isthme des risques psychosociaux alors
puisque c'est déjà un pas du titre
la deuxième question c'est sur
l'évaluation de l'évolution des métiers
nous avons une cellule de prospective à
la différence qu'ils travaillent sur ces
sujets là et on commence à voir
apparaître heures 6 a été dit par
monsieur qui avait une évolution dans
l'arrogance avoir à 10 salariés qui
étaient dans l'entreprise
lui qui aurait été magnifié le puits
dont l'entreprise a considéré qu'elle
n'avait pas forcément besoin de les
avoir sous un statut de salarié tout en
continuant à travailler avec et puis et
où des entreprises qui ont commencé à
considérer que ces salariés ne pouvait
ne plus être ni dans l'entreprise nîmes
hier à leur domicile rançon
domicile à l'étranger alors c'est pas
été utilisée pour se calmer pour
identifier cette évolution des mines si
encore une fois il est beau le jour à
marquer à la fois dans ce domaine et
dans la spec localisation et il avance
avoir foi dans l'aspect localisation
géographique et la spa du cheval du
deuil de la relation juridique entre
l'entreprise et le salarié avec délice
qui dans ce cas car voilà au moins un an
dans l'heure sa variété au bout d'un
moment
mais pourquoi le garder en statue en
salarié plutôt relativement à travailler
avec mesclun statut différent notamment
la boucle sur l'aspect risque pour les
seniors les personnes ayant répondu à
celle assez largement et plus tard je
veux c'est d'accord je ne sais pas
vraiment le cnra est plutôt à la voix
présent cadre à une question de
management de chaque division d'achat de
travail sincère d'animation et puis pan
l'habitude des nouvelles technologies
que l'asp et équipements qui peut être
décrite en arrêtant qu'un nul n'aurait
pas un équipement ou des ministres est
adéquat pour le pour les hommes
voilà le nombre d'animaux le cas merci
merci monsieur pervers je suis accélère
parce que malheureusement j'ai l'horloge
devant les yeux et c'est le stress des
des conférences je vais passer la parole
au troisième rapporteur fabien gay et
puis ensuite pour les questions de la
salle on a beaucoup parlé télétravail et
à juste raison je ne me revient pas et
vous avez raison ça touche plutôt un
public plutôt catégorie de cadres je
sens résumer comme ça et il ya d'autres
métiers qu'ils sont
disponible au télétravail je n'aime pas
beaucoup cette expression mais ce qu'on
a appelé les premiers de corvée et eux
ils ont été au travail et y compris
pendant la crise et il ya beaucoup de
choses qui m'ont parlé d humanisation
travail isolement enfin ça fait
longtemps que ça a commencé sa commande
et notamment il ya une question c'est
pour ce public là dont je parlais il ya
le recours à la sous-traitance
il faut bien qu'on évoque ça c'est pas
exactement la même chose par exemple
pour des hommes des femmes de ménage
d'être internaliser dans une entreprise
ou d être externalisés dans une
entreprise et on voit bien les risques
qui pèsent sur les travailleurs et les
travailleuses notamment lorsqu un
recours abusif à la sous-traitance
donc je voudrais avoir votre regard
d'expert sur cette question là et puis
la deuxième comme on à l'émergence et
l'impact des nouveaux modes de travail à
la deux qui nous intéresse par exemple
le recours aujourd'hui aux plateformes
numériques et aux travailleurs dits
indépendants en fait en réalité aux
salariés déguisés ou les grandes
entreprises comme du beurre etc détourne
le statut d'auto entrepreneur ou d'auto
entrepreneur est donc ça pose des
questions notamment de protection des
salariés
quel est votre regard parce que c'est un
public qu'on touche peu ou pas et c'est
ça la réalité est que la question de la
protection sociale y est très attaché
puis un deuxième chose d'honorant
devrait s'interroger c'est l'émergence
de ces grandes plateformes qui notamment
après font les livraisons et là je suis
désolé mais il ya eu beaucoup de
reportages notamment sur le service
public la semaine dernière sur les
méfaits de ces grandes plateformes et le
travail qui est déshumanisé robotisée
comme à l'époque on revient quasiment à
un siècle et ses effets médicaux sociaux
sur les travailleuses et les
travailleurs
donc je voulais avoir aussi votre regard
sur ces grandes plate forme et fini le
président sur la côte 19
vous avez parlé de reconnaissance de
maladie professionnelle ça a été
reconnue c'est un premier pas en
septembre pour les
les professionnels de la santé et du
médico social
c'est très bien même s'il ya beaucoup de
corps entrent dans le l'ordonance on
voit qu'il ya beaucoup de barrières
quand même mais enfin est ce que vous
seriez pour qu'on reconnaisse qu'on
élargisse cette liste parce qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de travailleuses et
travailleurs qui ont été contaminés par
la cofidis neuf et qui n'étaient pas
dans cette catégorie médico-sociaux donc
va se poser la question et notamment sur
les effets à long terme parce qu'être
passé quinze jours un tube et à
l'hôpital ça a quand même des effets à
long terme parce qu'on a on dit ça on
dit on veut pas plafonné au dessus de ça
me met enfin ceux qui y sont c'est quand
même avoir des effets à long terme
voilà je te remercie j'espère avoir pas
été trop lents merci fabien je vais
demander à pierre cuyper de poser sa
question dans la foulée oui nous courons
après parler très rapidement merci
monsieur le président j'ai bien écouté
tous les débats c'est très intéressant
et ça nous ouvre l'esprit
en fait ce sont des personnes des
salariés qui sont dans une entreprise
c'est qu'ils se trouvent dans les
conditions particulières dont qu'ils
connaissent bien l'entreprise le départ
et moi je voudrais avoir votre sentiment
votre ressenti sur les jeunes qui sont
eux post bac qui sont en situation
d'alternance et qui font pendant un an
travailler dans une entreprise
j'ai moi même des petits enfants qui ont
l'âge d'être en entreprise en fin
d'étude et qui ne se sont rentrés dans
une reprise sur la connaître et sans la
découvrir le même non plus sans avoir
cet esprit d'entreprise et qui sont
confinés pendant tout leur temps dans
une chambre dans our chez leurs parents
ou chez leurs grands parents ce qui est
mon cas mais qui n'ont aucun contact de
8 heures du matin à 19 heures le soir et
qui tu t'es quatre semaines se
retrouvent dans la même condition parce
que leurs universités dans lequel ils
sont obligés d'aller où ils ne peuvent
pas aller se fait aussi en
visioconférence en voilà c'était quelque
chose d'affreux servir on prépare des
jeunes qui ne connaissent pas là
prési l'esprit de l'entreprise je crois
que c'est un drame parce que c'est
l'entreprise de demain qui se construit
avec les jeunes aujourd'hui j'avais noté
justement au fur et à mesure que vous
entendez de parler ses plateformes et de
hubert et autres ne comptent pas kampala
la date c'est vrai quoi on s'est
beaucoup focalisé sur le traité du
travail mais le thème d'aujourd'hui si
j'avais même bien retenu je regarde
encore mon écran c'est bien d'une
nouvelle
comment c'était la vague des nouveaux
modes de travail et c'est vrai que ça
s'est vraiment si un poste de travail
complètement différent qui s'est ajoutée
qui s'est développée maintenant en plus
avec les restaurants qui sont fermés que
le consul ici c'est des gens que nous on
ne voit pas ils ont un statut
d'auto-entrepreneur même de si on dit
maintenant il faut salariés mais
clairement nous on ne les voit pas et ça
c'est un total de 2 de l'économie qui
échappent effectivement à nos services
de 200 t de santé au travail
ces salariés déguisés jory cas ce qu'il
a dit ça j'aime pâte est très importante
il a parlé en dernier de la colique 19
alors moi je vous disais tout à l'heure
que je fais partie du groupe de travail
à lens s sur justement les nouveaux
tableaux on n'a pas été sollicitée donc
le tableau était arrivé comme ça aussi
je le regrette
ne prendre que des gens qui ont été
hospitalisés qui ont été semées
d'oxygène s'est complètement à ses côtés
d'un certain nombre de gens qui gardent
des séquelles de ce qu'on appelle
maintenant le kobe de long alors ce que
je peux vous dire c'est qu'au niveau de
société française 2c travail où nous
avons été sollicités par la cs4 qui est
celle de cette commission au niveau du
cockpit qui réfléchit au tableau et aux
modifications tableau pour justement
donné nos connaissances sur ces formes
prolonger ses séquelles ou qui sont
peut-être mineurs
c'est vrai qu'en divin 2000 a glissé
dans les terres de doha du goût
c'est quelque chose qui peut être pas
vital mais qui au long cours est quand
même très regrettable et parfois de
difficultés difficilement de vie vécue
par par les gens enfin pour répondre ou
dernier intervenant sur les jeunes en
alternance c'est vrai et alors là c'est
le professeur d'université qui parlent
nos présidents d'université et celle de
tout faire pour reprendre les cours au
maximum dessus et c'est vrai que quand
je fais court façades et des écrans
comme aujourd'hui où je ne vois que des
petits rectangles grille avec les
initiales des pseudos etc
c'est extrêmement dommageable c'est pour
nous mais c'est bien sûr je compte bien
aussi que de l'autre côté c'est aussi
difficile à vivre et comme vous dites
vous sortez de l'enseignement vous
rentrez dans le supérieur et puis
finalement aucun contact ni avec
l'entreprise ni avec ses enseignants
je comprends ce soit extrêmement
extrêmement compliqué et on attend aussi
de pouvoir ouvrir au moins à minima pour
pouvoir avoir de meilleurs contacts avec
nos études
voilà je n'aime pas plus long que ce
qu'il est déjà parce que 20 je pense
qu'il ya d'autres intervenants qui
veulent aller re sic merci professeur je
vois que vous surveillez également
l'horloge c'est maintenant je vais
demander à chacun des trois autres
intervenants de conclure par voilà une
minute chacun pour reprendre au vol
quelques sujets qui n'ont pas pu être
approfondie malades vers les i pour cet
exercice terrible c'est ça je vais juste
dire deux choses donc pour répondre sur
la question des jeunes
effectivement on sait que on appelle ça
la socialisation organisationnel que
pour s'insérer professionnellement au
niveau socioprofessionnel pour apprendre
métier on apprend aussi en regardant
donc c'est important de se retrouver
physiquement et d'être en présentiel
avec les autres et une autre thématique
qui me tient à coeur dont on n'a pas du
tout parlé qui concerne encore le
télétravail mais c'est forcément mon
domaine de spécialité c'est la question
du renforcement possible des inégalités
entre les femmes et les hommes associés
au télétravail puisqu'on sait
aujourd'hui que on est dans des cultures
d'appréciation de l'engagement des
salariés par la présence et on sait
également que les femmes qui à une
répartition inégale des tâches
domestiques et des obligations
familiales qu'elles ont une double
charge mentale d'organisation du travail
et de la vie familiale et domestique et
elle risque à mon sens d'être davantage
pénalisés par le télétravail
du fait de ce déséquilibre existant et
du fait que le télétravail se déroule à
domicile et que c'est plus compliqué
pour elles de concilier vie
professionnelle et vie privée dans ce
cas là merci monsieur beaumont ont servi
aussi à des thématiques étaient abordés
dans cette cette matinée c'était la
qualité du travail
comment on peut la définir je pense que
ça fait référence aussi à la manière de
d'accompagner ces transformations
digital en la katibet au travail c'est
pas seulement offrir des environnements
des situations des conditions de travail
et d'exercice du travail qui soit
efficace efficient et et signifiant pour
l'individu ces trois temps trois termes
sont importants efficace efficace
efficient et signifiant mais c'est aussi
leur permettent de s'exprimer sur ces
conditions très comme on l'a dit tout en
ménageant n'est que ce soit sur des
moines était trahi distance sur une
nouvelle forme de travail sur
l'enseignement sur les transformations
qu'on subit cette s'exprimer c'est à
dire de dire ce qu'il veut ce qui ne va
pas et puis troisième niveau c'est de
pouvoir participer en amont pendant et
après tout le temps de mettre en place
des cités
un contexte de travail on puisse
réfléchir ensemble à partir de
l'activité saas est importante pas par
rapport à la tâche la tâche est ce que
pense que font les individus gilles
taschet c'est dans les bureaux c'est
très éloigné mais moi je suis confronté
au jour le jour tout le temps à des
réalités des contraintes qui font qu'ils
n'y arrivent pas et plus encore dans ce
nouvel environnement qui est distant
dans ses plateformes numériques on
m'impose effectivement de d'une
prescription ne dépossède de son
savoir-faire pour la confier à vous
connaissez les p'tits drôles spiky donc
à définir à déterminer voir des caméras
qui évalue la proximité des personnes
pour pas qu'ils se parlent oui comme ça
casse et collectifs ont 6 ou alors des
indicateurs qui oppose des individus aux
autres on se compare on se confronte aux
s'affrontent donc tout ça faut être
vigilant et pour dernière chose l'idée
c'est que c'est quoi le bien-être pour
moi le bien-être c'est ça repose sur
trois sur trois piliers le bien-être au
travail
1 c'est la qualité du travail c'est à
dire de pouvoir faire un travail dans
lequel on s'accomplit on se reconnaît on
est reconnu par les autres et là on voit
que l'intensification la fragmentation
les empêchements la possibilité de faire
un bon travail ne va pas
2 c'est la qualité de vie au travail
c'est à dire passer ces conditions de
réalisation à collectif un manager qui
est présent une organisation du travail
sous tenante qui donne de l'autonomie
mais pas trop mais discuter des outils
appropriés aussi et puis 3 c'est la
qualité de vie hors travail c'est à dire
cet espace du domicile qui nous permet
aussi d'apporter des ressources concerne
va pas on voit aussi qu'il a affecté
atteint ses trois niveaux là peuvent
jouer c'est là dessus qu'on doit
intervenir
[Musique]